[Musique]
james bond x 2 c'est ce à quoi vont
avoir droit les spectateurs français
les héros de ian fleming survient en
effet dans deux films et avec deux
comédiens le premier c'est roger moore
dans octobre ou 6 et le second est oui
c'est tout simplement sean connery
l'ancien james bond qui revient dans un
film intitulé jamais plus jamais vous en
parlerons lors de sa sortie au début de
l'année prochaine
mais dès ce soir france roche nous
confie à découvrir octopus i avec roger
moore
il est arrivé le 007 nouveau le bol
bonbons de l'année 83 il est robuste et
a du corps même en smoking et fête ses
21 ans de succès roger moore a un petit
peu plus de bouteille car il a dépassé
cet âge de plus de trente ans mais s'il
est toujours gouleyant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce bond de nouveaux octopus il ya aussi
de la robe et de la cuisse avec
christina web en blonde et mode adams
brune comme la nuit plus deux ou trois
douzaines de james bond girl de ce type
non pas celle ci ça c'est une chasse au
fouet le coeur lady di soi même qui
était venu à la première londonienne
féliciter son idole et même louis
jourdan qui joue le méchant s qui lui
demande son tour de taille angers mourra
la ville est en train de préparer un
autre coup de maître produire un film où
il jouerait avec son prédécesseur en
bande rit jaune conneries et en plus
michael caine
nous avons chacun des agents différents
qui met les choses en place il croit au
succès commercial avec les trois stars
qui rapporte le plus
nous avons un scénario prometteur je ne
vais pas terminée jaune aura sa copie la
semaine prochaine à son tour d'espagne
ce qu'elle vient un pur you pour le lire
et puis nous commencerons à nous
disputer pour savoir qui sera le premier
sur la piste et qui donnera le plus
d'argent
[Musique]